I was recently reviewed by Genetic Summary, near the beginning, under the section,
Peter's bolded caffeine. It says to avoid or limit caffeine,
text is bolded but not highlighted. Okay, so this is the Genetic Summary. So those of you that have
started with us in the last couple years, you know that you receive a full genetic report,
then you receive a Genetic Summary, and then you receive a Genetic Action Stamps. So in the Genetic
Summary, the boldly thing you need to pay attention to is the highlighted pieces. If it's not
highlighted, you don't need to pay attention to it. It wasn't an issue with your genes.
Later in the section on tumor suppressor genes, the HIF1A, it mentions that caffeine is a possible
intervention. What should I make of this? Also, if that wasn't highlighted, you could ignore
both those things. If it was highlighted, then caffeine, so just so you know, with HIF1A genes,
caffeine can help that gene work better. So that's another reason why I have told all of you
that drinking a little coffee is okay. I know there's naturopaths out there and natural doctors
that curse coffee and think coffee is just this evil beast that's destroyed our health. That's not
me. I don't believe that. If you look at any of the latest done bias studies, it actually shows that
coffee can be beneficial for a lot of things. However, caffeine itself, if you have the genes
of that first page in that summary, I don't remember the gene it is, that gene family,
if you don't, and I deleted that, then caffeine needs to be watched a little closer.
So, if you have a specific gene defect, you actually detox coffee quite well. I used to tell people
before that gene was identified, you could tell if a person detoxifies caffeine well as if they drink
coffee and they have the uridate. So, yeah, I love coffee. But yeah, typically if I drink a couple
cups of coffee, I have to go pee. Well, that's a good thing. You're getting rid of it. Over the years
of me practicing over the last 35 plus years, I've had people, I remember this one guy, this is not a
cancer patient. Decades ago, you drink seven cups of coffee a day. A couple cups of coffee a day.
This guy was a blue collar worker. He's the funniest guy in the world. I just loved this guy. He had
rheumatoid arthritis. And he had a serious coffee addiction. But I asked him, what do you go to the
bathroom all day? No, coffee doesn't make him pee at all. Well, caffeine was an issue with his
rheumatoid arthritis. He had a addiction to caffeine. And caffeine would stimulate, you know,
more damage to his joint capsule cell. So, we had to get him to cut way back on his caffeine and
just cutting back on his caffeine. There's no way we were going to eliminate it. It is life. He just
wasn't willing to do that. But it made a big difference in the symptoms. So, I don't think
everybody should be drinking, you know, a ton of caffeine every day, but a little bit of caffeine
can actually be beneficial for the HIF-1 aging. So, that's all I'll say about that. So, read the
instructions at the top of your genetic summary. It says, you're only looking at the highlighted
genes. And the highlighted genes are the ones that you have issues with. Nothing else.